montigny le bretonneux mort pas c'était
l'une des affiches de ces quarts de
finale de coupe des yvelines dès
l'entamé du match maurepas qui évolue en
d1 le district assume son statut de
favori sa division d'écart
le patient se procurent les meilleures
occasions y arrive à marquer deux fois 2
à 0 ce sera le score à la pause ça se
passe pas très bien on a respecté les
consignes du coach
après ils ont marqué sur une attaque
rapide et
ça fait contrer une deuxième au casque
qui met au fond voilà pour essayer de
faire le nécessaire pour revenir au déjà
2 1 après poussé pour ces d'égaliser sur
une tête juste garder la possession
essaie de faire ce qu'on a fait en
première mi-temps garder mon système
tranquillement le troisième va venir
sûrement tout seul ça va s'ouvrir un peu
plus espacés se livrer pour sortir pour
fournir au moins mettre le premier pour
nous titiller un peu d'amour ensemble
savoir le défenseur tristan feely a vu
juste quelques minutes après la reprise
yacoub belfodil réalise un petit numéro
dans la surface avant de marquer 3 0
savage arriva j'arrive à bien effacer
finir avec un petit piqué franchement
c'est j'ai bien aimé cela mais après je
garde tous et des buts
baup à bout un but un but pas encore
rassasié yacoub belfodil s'offre même un
triplé en fin de match maurepas
l'emportent 4 à 0 sera frais seront
éliminés salma a non bref pas grand
chose à dire les a parqués match de
coupe on aurait dit elle était un peu
plus de la femme étant entrés dans l
envie on a maîtrisé on savait que on
savait qu'on avait les qualités de
défense est fait aux français pour
pouvoir faire la différence si j'ai une
division en dessous ont conservé et
qu'on partait avec un petit avantage
après voilà maintenant on a su on a su
montrer l'écart cave entre le prochain
tour de la coupe des yvelines est
programmée le dimanche 5 avril
[Applaudissements]